deepmind's alpha code solves programming
challenges openai's language models
solve math problems and eluther ai
releases a 20 billion parameter language
model open source welcome to ml news
[Music]
before the rest of the video this video
is sponsored by weights and biases
weights and biases builds developer
tools for machine learning for
researchers for practitioners for
juniors for seniors whatever your
favorite flavor of yogurt is they don't
care they build products for you except
cherry who likes cherry
today i want to talk to you about a
feature called artifacts so artifacts
essentially are files in the cloud but
you're probably going to use them mostly
for two things data and models both of
these things are notoriously tricky to
work with dataset is too large to check
in to get we need to keep it up to date
we may have different versions of it and
models even more we want to save the
outputs of our runs into models that we
can then use later maybe introspect and
these things are also versioned and we
want to depend on them so when i did
this i had to save the model to some
special folder and then i had to go grab
it from that folder put it on all the
machines in a correct folder and then
reference that folder from all my
scripts that would then consume this
model with artifacts this gets a lot
easier so we first uploaded the original
data set to an artifact now we're gonna
consume that artifact split the data
into train validation and test data and
then emit those things as artifacts so
if there's a new version of the raw data
available i can simply run the same
script depending on the same thing and
it will create new versions of the train
validation and test data you can make
this arbitrarily complex but i hope you
can see the point here the same goes for
models if your run outputs and saves
some kind of a model you can log that as
an artifact and from then on you can
consume that model in all subsequent
runs here's one of my models it's a cnn
you can see it's already version 116 of
that model but you can see all i have to
do to use this model in any code in any
script in the future i simply call the
download method on the artifact and it
will be available locally and as i told
you you can do this with any file but
since this is a model of a deep learning
framework weights and biases understands
it and gives me a neat viewer where i
can actually introspect the model and
look at the shapes and even at the
weights of my cnn so i think this is
incredibly powerful these things quickly
get complicated with versions and
scripts building upon other scripts and
the artifact framework really helps you
to make sense of all of it there's even
a possibility that the data stays in
specific private buckets with access
controls so not everyone in your team
has access to all of the data of course
artifacts are only one of the features
of weights and biases if you're
interested please check them out free
accounts are free academic accounts are
free enterprise accounts cost a bit and
that's it for this week's sponsor spot
thanks a lot to weights and biases let's
get into the video
[Music]
hello and welcome to ml news how's
everyone doing we'll jump into our first
story which is that deepmind has
released alpha code which is a model
that can take a programming challenge
description you might know these
descriptions if you've ever done
competitive programming or had a
programming exam or something like this
so we have one right here given two
strings s and t both consisting of
lowercase english letters this is kind
of overly formal about but it kind of
details a procedure so you can press the
backspace button and as you type the
string s and then the character is
deleted and the question is can you get
from the string s to the string t by
pressing the backspace button at the
appropriate times so for example here is
the input you have four inputs the first
string is a b a b a that's s and b a is
t the question is can you type s and you
always have the choice of typing the
button of the letter or the backspace
button and you have to end up at t so
we'll try this for example first type a
backspace right
then
there's nothing then we'll type b a and
then we'll type b
and then a backspace and all of that
should result in ba so we are going to
have to write a program that figures out
if it is possible to get uh 2t from s
and they have a bunch of these example
inputs right here they have some notes
and as you can see this is a text
description this is the problem you feed
this to a neural network the neural
network will output a program a an
actual piece of code in this case python
code that actually reads the input from
the provided file not only these by the
way so there's going to be other test
cases not just the ones that they have
as an example right here implements the
algorithm all by itself there's no human
in the loop right here and then prints
out the correct answer according to the
specification in the textual description
of the problem this is let's say
quite challenging this is a hard problem
especially given the description is in
natural language and alpha code solves
this so they have submitted alpha code
to programming challenge competitions
and it scored at about a 50th percentile
of humans now that is not super duper
good as lots of these programming
challenge computers are maybe students
people who get into programming who kind
of want to prepare for an interview or
hone their skills a little bit so it is
at an intermediate level right now but
it is definitely more than i would have
expected so the way the model works is
that kind of like codecs it is
pre-trained on github problems but then
it is fine-tuned to solve exactly these
code challenge data sets so there exists
data sets given problems in natural
language description and solutions and
the solutions are programs obviously so
deepmind takes their pre-trained model
and then fine-tunes it on these pairs of
problem description and solution now
when it comes to actually solving a
problem at inference time they take that
problem description they feed it to the
network but they don't just output
whatever the most likely output of the
model is they actually sample a giant
amount of possible samples which means
possible programs that the models
suggest now a lot of them are going to
be wrong so what they do is they filter
those programs based on the small subset
of provided solutions that you get in
the problem descriptions in this case
here they have four different example
inputs four different example outputs
that will filter out in the paper they
say that will filter out over 99
of possible solutions very often now
filtering alone isn't enough as that
still leaves them with a large number of
potential solutions and very often these
coding competitions they are limited to
a very small number of submissions in
this case i believe it was 10
submissions so in order to achieve that
they have a step on top of that where
they cluster solutions so they try to
cluster together programs that are
textually different but essentially
don't do a different thing like maybe
the variable names are different maybe
the same algorithm is implemented in a
slightly different way so they have a
clustering algorithm that lumps those
together and that brings them down to
the 10 submissions that they're going to
make these are not the only parts of the
system by any means there is a large
number of components to this system that
really brings up the system to the level
of the average human where it currently
stands now there's a website where you
can explore the solutions given by the
model and you can look at sort of the
attention heads of the different models
like what they pay attention to along
the different types and things they do
so on the left here you see the
description of the exact problem we saw
before this is pure text with natural
language and on the right you see the
solution so as you hover over this right
here it shows you token probabilities
and it shows you according to what this
token is decided upon so for example
when i say when i hover over the line s
is the input right here you can see that
on the left it focuses on this text
right here on the first line of each
test contains the string s when i focus
on t it focuses mostly on the line below
where it describes whatever t is the
attention is not only to the problem
description but also within the program
that was already generated and it's
generally pretty cool to explore i
recommend you give it a try as i said
there is a detailed paper with this
where they describe exactly what the
components of the system are and so on
give it a read it is quite a lengthy
paper i believe it has its own table of
contents yes it does about 30 pages so
not too long so my question is a little
bit when i think back at like alphago
alpha zero and so on those models also
didn't start out world class but they
were able to quickly get there and
beyond simply by doing more self play in
this case it seems the data set is a
limiting factor so there's only a finite
amount of these human generated
programming competition data points the
question would be is there a way that we
could come up with synthetic data like
synthetically produced code samples and
is there a way that we could make them
progressively harder and harder and
harder in a self-play kind of style
because if that's the case and if we
really get this data generation part
right it could also be that the coding
ai here will become you know like uh
good beyond limits but i am kind of
skeptical about that we also have some
different voices giving their opinions
on this one of these for example is
dimitri vadanao who is a competitive
programmer has done this for a while
apparently and puts it a little bit into
perspective saying it is impressive yes
but he says human level is still light
years away mentions again that 50th
percentile in these competitions doesn't
necessarily mean that it's particularly
good that a human challenge is often not
only the difficulties of the problems
but also the limited time you have
available for them and the disparity
between humans and the machine of the
approach namely that 99 of all programs
that alpha code outputs are wrong
whereas a human will maybe make a
mistake in the first try of the
implementation but doesn't need to
generate thousands and thousands of
hypotheses until they get a correct one
and certainly they don't evaluate all of
these hypotheses by filtering them using
the tiny tiny amount of examples they
have so humans and machines they seem to
have a sort of fundamentally different
approach for now to solving these
problems yet i can definitely see a
version of alpha code that more
iteratively takes into account sort of
partial programs and more does a more
guided search for the the rest and
ultimately yeah humans also they they
run their program on the small test
examples and if that doesn't work out
they're like wait something's wrong so
this is an exciting field i'm i'm very
curious where it goes
next news open ai releases a blog post
called solving some formal math olympiad
problems they detail how a language
model that was fine-tuned is able to
solve formal mathematics problems this
is very very cool so other than in alpha
code these problems actually come with a
formal description they they are defined
in a formal language that is amenable to
be proven yet still to apply language
modeling to this problem and then do
some post-processing obviously is quite
a hard task so the reason they use
language modeling right here is that
other than in chess or anything like
this the action space is huge it's
actually infinite improving formal
mathematics because you can just invent
new things by yourself they do have a
set of tactics that the model is kind of
allowed to apply but still the action
space is infinite and the language model
helps them to determine what are the
most likely next steps that they want to
do if they want to solve this proof the
other thing that differentiates them
from games is what they call the lack of
self-play opportunity there there's no
reward two people playing against each
other or anything like this which
usually serves as sort of a curriculum
method as the agents play against each
other they sort of level each other up
in skill now to combat that they have
quite a smart data generation and
sampling process where they start off
with some hand provided samples of
various difficulties of where they want
to go and then they start with the
lowest ones that they might be able to
prove with the current technique of
language model plus proof search note
that it is not only a language model
it's combined actually with a proof
searcher that is guided by a language
model and as they prove more things in
the let's say easier statements they add
those to the data set which they then
reuse to train the language model so in
this case the model automates its own
curriculum by proving more and more
statements now this isn't obviously
without challenge because math is full
of trivial and nonsensical statements
that you can prove to be true so
choosing even what to prove becomes our
task but nevertheless using this
approach they're able to generate quite
good proofs in fact they're able to
outperform pure proof search by quite a
bit they're also able to solve problems
of the international math olympiad which
is usually quite a hard problem there is
a paper to go along with this give it a
read if you are interested
a luther ai announces gpt neo x20 b that
is a 20 billion parameter model and by
the time you're watching this the model
is going to be available for free it's
gonna be kind of a pain to run it
because it's so big but you can just
download it i've made an entire video
interviewing connor leahy who is one of
the co-founders of luther and has worked
on this project about how this came to
be about how they you know got their
hands on the hardware necessary and so
on so if you're interested check that
out
another new paper about stylegan xl the
paper is called scaling stylegan to
large diverse datasets that is a hard
thing to say scaling stylegan like try
saying that over and over again scaling
style gan so the tldr here is with the
right training strategy stylegan
achieves state of the art on imagenet so
if you remember stylegan always used to
be trained on very specific data sets
diagon is the thing that powers this
person does not exist.com this shoe does
not exist dot com this sneaker does not
exist dot com and so on but these are
all very limited data sets often of the
same thing and approaches like big gan
have traditionally been better at
modeling diverse data sets such as
imagenet which has many different things
the authors here show that with the
right training protocol namely projected
gans up sampling and so on progressive
training you can get these gans to the
level of imagenet this is also built on
stalgan v3 which means that it kind of
retains it has these translation
invariants properties i have reported on
this on ml news previously so go check
that out if you are interested so
they're able to generate images up until
10 24 to 10 10 24 resolution which is
quite impressive they can also invert
images on the left you actually see a
real image and on the right is an
inverted image where they have fed this
into the gan and then figured out the
latent codes and then they're able to
edit the image on the right as they see
fit and as i said it retains the
translation equivariance from stylgan 3.
if you're interested check out their
website and check out their paper
r55 it's ar 5 iv that is a website it's
ar5iv.org
what it allows you to do it allows you
to view archive articles as html5 web
pages i'm not exactly sure how it's
pronounced i was told it's pronounced r5
but then again it should probably be r5
like the way it's written i don't know
also uh the browser showed me a warning
when i went on this website asking me
whether or not i have maybe confused it
with archive so yeah this might be just
a giant phishing attack but it is pretty
cool here is an example that they give
now my browser is dark mode so i don't
know if that's available in light mode
but you can see that the references are
real true links that you can open as a
pop-up there are still some kind of
artifacts right here as you can see
equations are rendered nicely and also
the side note the footnotes here are
rendered right beside the text i don't
know what happens if i zoom in
okay they just start pop over also it
allows you to jump to equations and then
using the back button jump back to where
you were this is like this is the
greatest thing ever the amount of times
i had not clicked on like an internal
reference on a pdf just because i was
like no i i'm not gonna scroll back to
where i was so thank you check out r5
[Music]
okay we have some helpful things this
week uh the first helpful thing is yitai
saying they've released over 170
pre-trained transformer checkpoints of
many different shapes and sizes as part
of their paper this is by google
research check out the scaling
transformers paper the scaling
transformers repo and the models
released thank you ffcv is a library by
the lab of alexander madhuri that makes
training machine learning models fast if
there is ever like a buzzwordy title
that says nothing it's train machine
learning models fast so they provide a
set of sort of throw in replacements for
example for data loaders that will just
kind of speed up common use cases of
training neural networks they claim
their code is hyper optimized removes
bottlenecks it's super duper pipeline
and parallel and all of that so if speed
is an issue for you maybe give this a
try ott or optimal transport tools is a
toolbox for all things wasserstein as
they call it it is an optimal transport
library for jax sumit tintala advertises
diet gpu which is a lossless compression
algorithm for nvidia gpus the code of
this is available it's authored by jeff
johnson and what it does is it can
compress stuff and uncompress stuff on
gpus so if you have a slow network and
you have a distributed training and you
really care about making this fast and
efficient what you can do is you can
compress stuff that you need to send
over the network on the gpus send it
over then uncompress it this library
will make the compression and
uncompression part really fast and
really efficient all right that was it
for helpful things i hope you got help
the user bremen 79 on reddit says the
icml 2022 conference is changing their
review process slightly so now there are
two phases in phase one the reviewers
just give a recommendation if there are
two recommendations that are negative
for a paper in phase one it is already
rejected i guess this is a goal to call
down on the amount of papers that have
to be seriously reviewed uh it's all the
more important now that your paper makes
a good first impression so they say the
meta reviewer can reverse this outcome
okay another change is that reviewers do
not make accept or reject
recommendations in phase two the meta
reviewers will decide based on the
reviews so i just write my review and
then the metroview reads it and
integrates it all instead of me saying
well this is a seven or this is a four
or this is a strong acceptor a week
except now technically it shouldn't make
a difference right because me voice like
my score that i would usually put is
just kind of a conglomeration of what i
said before but you know tiny changes
like this you know because we're humans
and we're not consistent and and we're
not you know uh we're not attentive
enough tiny changes might like this
might actually make a difference i'd be
interested to see some statistical
analysis after the fact of what this did
if you're interested the entire process
is detailed in the icml 2022 review form
now it just occurred to me that the
submission deadline was actually last
week uh which i should know so if your
paper is not pretty and doesn't make a
good first impression then you just you
just gotta gotta hope for that really
good meta reviewer that recognizes its
inner beauty
this is a little bit older but i hadn't
seen it at the time there is a blog post
on meta ai's research blog saying
harmful content can evolve quickly our
new ai system adapts to tackle it so
they describe a system that they call
few shop learner which essentially means
that it's a system that can monitor
harmful content and adapt quickly to new
harmful content because it's ever
evolving i find a few things interesting
right here first on a sort of a
scientific level what is pretty
interesting is that the model doesn't
only consider training data so data that
has been labeled as harmful or not
harmful or borderline or anything like
this it does do that but it also takes a
description of the policy like a textual
description of the current policy and by
doing that it's able to adapt to
policies over time having seen you know
with this policy this stuff is okay and
then with this new policy this other
stuff is okay so the fine-tuning process
can potentially happen with less data i
found this pretty pretty interesting to
actually provide the policy itself to
the model the other interesting thing is
just this video right here so as you can
see the uh people here they're
interacting with with the internet and
and they see harmful content and they're
like uh like they're like oh no i'm
gonna log all oh no
all this harmful content and then you
know there's the system they describe
their system
ah yeah whoa okay so now they you know
they filter all of this this new harmful
content and then at the end look what
happens
wha everyone's smiling like look they're
smiling like oh ah this is just it is so
awesome thank you thank you metta thank
you
the few shot learner thank god all the
harmful content was prevented from
destroying smiles
now okay on a more serious note it is a
hard problem right
there's no way you can monitor all the
content all the time there's no way you
can train a static system because sort
of the meta of of bad content of bad
language of people bullying each other
and so on is always evolving so props to
you know meta for for actually trying to
tackle this problem because what i mean
what's the alternative shut down all
communication that's not going to happen
tell people to be nice like
well try but i see a bit too much
complaining about this and yeah i do i
do like that they're actually tackling
this problem and i find the approach to
be cool it's just the marketing that's a
bit cringy but what am i saying i'm
wearing sunglasses indoors
okay last news for the day mit
technology review says this company says
it's developing a system that can
recognize your face from just your dna
now people have been extremely skeptical
of statements like these this is a
company that deals in broad language
with law enforcement
searching people security surveillance
and so on and you know you might debate
the merits or on merits of that in a
separate topic but the particular
question of can we actually get
someone's facial features from their dna
is highly debated just to be said the
company isn't only focused on that it's
called coresight and they have different
plans these are not systems that run
right now these are sort of future plans
to do things one of them is this dna to
face thing now i do feel the criticisms
of this are often maybe overly skeptical
let's say now again i i don't mind the
skepticism about the applications of
this but the possibility that there's a
reason that children often look like
their parents your facial structure is
in large part determined by your genetic
material now the article points out that
obviously age and environmental
influences also have big impacts on that
so no doubt about that and they make a
good point in that they say the
technology will probably not be able to
tell you the exact number of millimeters
between the eyes or the ratios between
the eyes nose and mouth and those are
some of the features that the current
facial recognition technologies rely
upon so since we can't get those
features accurately from genetic data
because there may be more
environmentally determined the current
facial recognition algorithms wouldn't
work however i don't see the
extrapolation discussed right here in
that i would think it might be
absolutely possible to train facial
recognition algorithms that only use the
features that we can read from the dna
like the argument that the face
reconstructions that the dna data gives
us doesn't work with current facial
recognition software is almost a moot
point by then question is obviously how
accurate it's going to be and again
whether or not you even want to do this
in the first place but let me know what
you think should this be done can this
be done and uh would you want to do it
let me know in the comments i this was
ml news thank you so much for being here
i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you